i mean there's a lot that can be done i
think step one is realizing or just
becoming more aware aware of how fear
might be impacting
um how you show up either as a leader
how you show up in relationship with
other people and and how you show up as
a leader of change in
your respective organization
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet mark
minookas managing partner co-creation
partners an engineer by training he
began his career as a navy officer and
member of the us naval construction
battalions seabees and the navy dive
community in 2005 he brought his
experience and insights on human and
organizational factors and engineered
systems to mckinsey company where he
worked as a consultant and member of the
operations practice
since leaving mckinsey to join
co-creation partners marked his work
across multiple industries including
financial services technology
manufacturing i.t services and
governmental offices to deliver both top
and bottom line improvements and build
high performing cultures
mark menucos welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
how are you today
[Music]
yeah thanks for having me michael doing
well
thank you very much for joining me mark
um i'm excited to talk about you know
leadership in in a different way you
know a lot of times i talk about
leadership in this show through you know
experiences in the high tech company or
through leading others today we're going
to be talking also about fear and your
book on fear but also a little bit about
organizations and and the way we place
ourselves in them as well as your own
personal journey
we're gonna start off with with your
experience co-owning two crossfit gyms
and i'm gonna have to understand why and
what you learned from that but you know
you're an engineer by profession in the
newest naval a construction battalion
you're the managing a director of
co-creation partners and you're you're
looking at you know how do we allow
people to be their best selves and to
break break whatever barriers they may
have and so i'm excited for these 20
minutes mark tell me a little bit about
yourself and then
share with me the story of
co-owning two crossfit gyms
yeah absolutely so yeah the the broad
you know arc of my life i started off my
career as an engineer i was in the navy
for a period of time
and then completely shifted gears into
management consulting
for the longest time i i always felt
like
uh you know true to how i was trained as
an engineer there was always one right
answer
to any any problem in any solution and i
found that in leadership and in
organizational transformation
that was a very limiting idea and i
have discovered through a lot of trial
and error over time that
you know
real effective leadership and sustained
organizational change happens when you
focus on the human dimension as well as
the technical dimension and that means
there isn't just one right right
solution there's just a lot of sort of
you know messiness and
um
ambiguity that that we have to wade into
and and deal with and so that's kind of
been the the arc of my life um and
that's you know
um
played out as well i'm a dad to uh two
young girls who are nine and six so that
you know
that human dimension is very much a part
of that and
you mentioned i do some other projects
like co-owning crossfit gyms and you
know that's been uh you know a labor of
trying to understand how people can you
know perform at a higher level but
uh you know helping people overcome you
know some of their their limiting
beliefs to you know achieve higher
levels of performance and well-being
beautiful so do you see the the
entrepreneurial endeavor of co-owning
those gyms is that more on the side of
you know continuing to help people be
their best selves and breaking barriers
now also in the physical world and not
not just in the professional world and
and is that the main motivation for this
or is there or is it more you know for
your learning and for business related
i for me i think it's all the above um
you know i started off crossfit i fell
in love with it you know the first first
day i stepped into a crossfit gym
and i really appreciated how it
challenged conventional wisdom about
what it meant to you know work out and
pursue fitness
um
you know just by having a military
background i feel like i you know
essentially wasted my time you know
working out in gyms you know doing
um
you know the standard back and bicep day
and you know the leg day and and
crossfit just really kind of blew all
that up and you know rearranged uh you
know how workouts can be done and and
elevated the level of intensity um that
i felt like i could actually
apply and use and i saw a lot of other
people making such great progress that
um
yeah so i think you know i got into
crossfit because
i was drawn to the the
um
you know the challenge of you know the
underlying assumptions about what it
means to to be fit and i was also uh
wanting to become a an owner of a
crossfit gym because i saw the impact it
was having on people's lives and i also
just wanted to learn
um you know what it takes to actually
create and run your own business you
know at the time i was just you know
management consultants and you know it's
one thing to do the analysis and give
advice to other people it's a very
different thing to actually own your own
business and deal with all the messiness
uh you know that that comes with that so
um it's been a wonderful learning
journey on many levels and obviously
you did it also with mckenzie and so
obviously you know
the things that you did you were you
know in the hi in the highest standards
and to me it's you know also it's just
inspirational this idea that you're
understanding that you're doing a part
of a part of the journey and and you
want to experience the other part as
well and so mark tell me a little bit
about fear
what does that mean
to you
um yeah so fear
yeah so i i you know recently co-wrote a
book with my business partner gaurav
butnagar on fear in organizations
and the reason we wrote that book
is because in our experience
fear sort of sat at the root of a lot of
you know both performance and well-being
issues
and we've discovered over time that in
order to create real performance and do
it in a sustainable way that that
creates uh better well-being
you have to change how people relate to
to fear so what does fear mean fear is
just part of the human condition and a
lot of times we as leaders believe that
we either need to create pressure in
ourselves or others to generate results
and that works but there's a long-term
consequence of that
or
we believe that we have to eliminate and
suppress fear and be fearless and in all
that but you know fear is just
um it's neither good or bad it's just
part of the the human condition it's
just it's part of you know we're built
for survival in a way and so fear is
inherently useful
but we either have a constructive you
know positive relationship with that
fear and see it as a cue for learning
and growth or creates patterns that
you know create waste and dysfunction in
our lives and so
a long way of saying fear is just it's
just part of what we experience in life
and how we hold it is what
leads to
the outcomes that we experience
and so what is there to be done in in
your in you and your partner's eyes in
terms of
fear especially when it comes into your
professional life and organizations
yeah i think the i mean there's a lot
that can be done i think step one is
realizing or just becoming more aware
aware of how fear might be impacting
um how you show up either as a leader
how you show up in relationship with
other people and and how you show up as
a leader of change in
your respective organization
and a lot of people are blind to
the patterns that are not really
effective
so for instance in my life uh you know
i've been a very competitive person uh i
started i can't tell um you know
yeah right so with crossfit but you know
going back to i was a a golfer in
college and you know just super
competitive person tried to do the best
in in school and get get all a's and for
a while that that served me quite well
but i was also driven by fear you know
very deep fear of failure of
rejection of of isolation and not not
belonging and for the longest time i
didn't really see that you know i felt
stress
i probably felt some anxiety
um but i channeled that into competitive
uh
you know pursuits and it worked quite
well for me you know i got got into good
schools and got into good companies but
at some point i looked back and was like
wow i you know this is actually not
serving me i've realized uh
you know there's all kinds of uh you
know waste and destruction about me um
that i was just blind to so step one is
just becoming aware of how you know fear
is driving what you do and how it might
not be working well for you
right
now
as you as i go about that how do i even
you know what are some tangible ways for
me to exercise
my understanding of of
what what is the fear and still okay so
i'm i'm exhibiting these symptoms
because of a fear so that i even know
that i want to tackle it
yeah
yeah so one thing we talked about in our
book is uh we describe these eight fear
archetypes but they're basically
patterns of behavior that
you know people tend to demonstrate in
the face of fear interesting and the
fear archetypes are ones that generally
have a lot of downsides to them there's
some upsides but there's some downsides
associated with them so there's there's
two broad categories of of archetypes
that we talk about
um one is uh ones that are you know sort
of aggressive or based on a fight
response
and the others are
more passive and based on
flight and freeze responses so the four
aggressive responses are perfectionism
and competitiveness
uh and controlling behaviors and
fault-finding behaviors
and so these are you know just attempts
by people to manage their own fear by
standing out and being special
and and trying to be you know better
than than other people
right and for a lot of people they they
probably
these patterns we see them all over the
business world and they serve us in some
ways but uh we're often blind to the
ways that they're really not serving us
and then the passive archetypes uh we
call them the likables so those are
people who you know are trying to uh you
know be nice but not really being on
honest with other people
uh we have the sticklers you know that
they'll throw the rulebook at you
the minions these are people just their
only boss is uh or the only customer is
the boss i should say and then avoiders
you know these are the people that would
do anything just to avoid conflict and
in confrontation
and again they serve people in in many
ways but then there's a lot of
dysfunction so
to get back to your original question
about uh you know what does it take to
address fear you know for ourselves and
organizations step one is just becoming
aware of of these patterns and
recognizing that it's not all upside
right can you take me back to your life
a little bit
what were your experiences with
you know with the world that that have
led you to to understand this more more
concretely and and become so passionate
to be thinking about it to the point
where you're writing a book about fear
and then helping others you know unfear
you know within their life
yeah it's a great question
um yeah because i don't know that i'm
the typical person to be talking about a
lot of this stuff um you know i'm not
aware of a lot of people with
engineering backgrounds who talk about
organizational culture and all this soft
stuff
but
i've you know throughout my life i
there's been a couple of
experiences that have sort of led me to
do this work
uh you know one is just you know being
in the the navy and and being in an
environment where uh leadership is a big
part of what you do
so i learned you know through you know
both good and bad examples of of
leadership you know what does it mean to
uh be an effective leader to take care
of people
uh to help people work through their
their fears so i just intuitively had
some experience uh with that when i was
in graduate school at uc berkeley i also
studied human factors and engineered
systems so i was already starting to
think about
um you know not just the technical
solution as being something you need to
focus on but there's something about how
human beings show up and how they're
organized that ultimately determine
whether or not um
an engineered system or organization
uh performs well
and then when i
you know shifted into management
consulting
i was
you know very focused on the technical
dimensions and you know uh you know the
the general way of of uh high priority
consulting is you tend to create a lot
of fear in organizations because that
creates quick movements but i found
myself coming back you know six to 12
months later
to many of my clients and seeing that
those results you know all our brilliant
plans and our brilliant solutions
weren't sustained
and i you know that was frustrating for
me you know both for the people that i
worked with but also
as someone who was interested in
organizational performance and i you
know
continually become more you know more
appreciative
of these deeper
mindset issues and even deeper than that
just the fears that we hold as being
that sort of leverage point to create
better systems
now is there room for
managers team leaders ceos
c-level executives to
think more concretely about
about fear within their organization is
there is there a way to even do that
obviously you know until now we've
talked about you know the personal fear
of every person figuring out what
archetype they are
but
how do leaders how should leaders
interact with this concept
well i think first just recognizing that
it's it's there and then there's a whole
variety of you know specific uh mindsets
and practices that people can
um you know consider and and play around
with that would help them
change how they relate to to their fears
so
um
i'll just you know list out a couple but
one is is mindfulness you know
mindfulness is you know it used to be in
the the realm of just the the spiritual
um minded people but it's becoming
something that's that is more more
mainstream and you know at least the way
i
would define it is it's simply becoming
more aware of
what's going on in your own mind at any
given point in time and so a lot of
times we're quite lost in thought
and we haven't really developed a
practice to
really you know be more aware of what's
going on in our body and you know what's
what sort of emotional state are we in
and what sort of mood do we have in any
given moment and so just strengthening
that muscle is is something that's very
practical and concrete for people to do
another one is learning how to
have effective difficult conversations a
lot of times
uh you know people are stuck and you
know mindset of right and wrong versus
um effectiveness and so that changes how
we show up in conversation with other
people
and so if we're believing that we're
right and other people are wrong we have
conversations in one way but if we can
show up with a mindset of effectiveness
we can show up and share what's going on
for us but also listen and tune into
what's going on with other people in a
very different way and that creates more
movement in relationships and develops
more trust and that that creates you
know both higher performance and better
well-being in teams
right
now
i want to go back a little bit to
your childhood not
you know be before the military before
golf you know i want to hear more about
you as an engineer also sort of in the
mindset
and what really fascinated you growing
up so today obviously you're fascinated
by human factors and behavior in the
intersection of engineering and
organizations
but what what were you curious about
growing up when you were just you know
going to elementary school middle school
hmm
taking me way back
yes yeah i was a curious kid i mean i
i think as a child
so there's you know
i guess going back to fear a little bit
um
is as a kid
i struggle to fit in
i struggle to fit in like a you know a
lot of kids probably feel so um you know
i felt the pain of you know rejection
and not being invited to the things and
you know maybe not uh being picked to
you know be on
um you know the sports team that i
wanted to be on you know was cut from
you know my uh baseball team in junior
high school for instance you know and
those those sort of experiences really
really stuck with me so i think that you
know informed my competitive
orientation in the world
um but what fascinated me as a as a kid
was how things worked as well i was just
always fascinated by
um you know how both mechanical things
work but also just how people worked and
how
you know how the environment works so i
don't know i've always been a bit of a
systems thinker as i guess is one way to
put it
i love it and what inspires you to do
the work that you're doing so besides
you know the curiosity that you have for
your field
where do you where do you gather your
your own inspiration
yeah it might sound a bit right but um
having a positive impact on people's
lives and i'll make that very very
concrete you know there's there are
times where i will hear back from
someone after you know having worked
with them a couple of years ago
and they'll come back and say hey the
the things i've learned with you with
co-creation partners is continue to have
this you know
really significant impact in my life and
i've recently figured out how to be more
effective at work and i got a promotion
and my personal life is better hearing
those stories
uh are actually what sustained me it's
always nice to have you know business
success but you know really
feeling like i'm getting through to the
people and that they're figuring out for
themselves how they can live a better
life is
actually really inspiring
amazing and if you had to choose a few
words to describe yourself
what would they be
um i would say
uh
dad systems thinker
and
wanderer
i'm constantly one systems thinker and
wanderer i love it mark thank you very
very much this is wonderful thank you
for the inspiration thank you for all
the good that you're doing to people and
stay safe and stay healthy
likewise michael thank you so much